so this is such an exciting season of
celebrity big brother the the
houseguests are so impressive from
reality stars a former nba champion and
90s boy band member my personal favorite
how pivotal is casting especially when
it comes to the celebrity edition of
this show
casting a celebrity edition of big
brother is
so layered you know you want a diverse
group
you want names that people of all ages
will recognize so like yeah you know
what todd bridges uh you look a little
too young to know who he is so i can
sleep a little bit
okay listen up
do you know the line
what you talking about willis do you
know that yes i do yes
he's willis
okay i got you okay children
that line would not exist without todd
bridges um but we also want people who
like you know my 12 year old son loves
youtube uh youtuber todrick hall who i
mean he travels the world performing and
he's a singer songwriter choreographer
he's been on broadway so you want people
from um
you want a diverse cast you want people
from different walks of life who are
used to being you know a star in their
own right whether yes i know you're an
nsync fan so we have one of the founding
members we have chris kirkpatrick you
also want people who you know we have a
former olympian in there who's a gold
medalist her name is mariah nagasu
figure skater she has a bronze medal
home
so you want people who come from the
world of real housewives and from the
nba we have lamar odom you know emmy
winner we have chris katan who spent
years on saturday night live
um so casting it is you want people of
different ages
and fame from different walks of life
like i'm not the biggest ufc fighter um
watcher but you know so when they said
we have misha tate and you know she took
on ronda rousey and you know she's a mom
of two i'm like oh i wanna i wanna watch
her i wanna learn more you know just by
that thumbnail sketch so um it's a mix
of people i don't
if you're someone who knows every single
name
then i'm really impressed by you
yeah
well a lot of people are buzzing
obviously over shayna mochler and lamar
odom because of their strong connection
to the kardashian family i mean people
are dying to see if they're gonna bond
over this you know mutual alliance to
this family what do you think is gonna
happen
well
should i explain to people the bouncing
ball of the connection between lamar
yes you should okay here we go
sit down and grab a cup of cocoa
because i know they're in canada all
right so shana moakler used to be i like
that shayna mookler used to be miss usa
then she marries travis barker who's the
drummer of blink 182 at their height of
fame
and they get their own reality show
called meet the barkers they have a son
they have a daughter they are now
divorced and those kids are now 18 and
16.
her ex-husband recently got engaged to
kourtney kardashian the oldest of the
kardashian girls
and lamar odom who you know from
being a two-time nba laker champion
he used to be married for four years
to courtney's younger sister khloe
kardashian
by like is that one degree of separation
one and a half two point seven five i
don't know
but i do know that shayna mokler
who is a super fan of the show
was very excited to be cast she was
fearful that maybe a kardashian might be
moving in as well because you know the
father of her two children just got
engaged to
kourtney kardashian
um now she is roommates with
lamar who was once married and part of
that you know whole big family
um so i think the name kardashian is
going to come up quite a few times i
don't know what's going to be said i do
know that lamar has publicly said that
he misses chloe i think life may have
moved on for her i don't keep close
watching every beat and you know lord
only knows what is in someone's heart
but um i think chloe's still in his
heart he's been saying that and i think
lamar is someone who wants to show the
world that um he's a survivor and he's a
changed man that he is clean he is sober
and that he loves jesus and i'm with him
on that train let me tell you yeah i
have to tell you how impressive that was
i know that i'm sure you've said this
before with that hole connecting
everyone now everyone is up to date on
what's going on
hopefully i got one or two facts right
in there you did you've got the whole
thing right that was so impressive
um so we have interviewed carson and he
said you know that he is the reality
queen when it comes to reality stars
coming into the big brother house do you
find that there's a bit of ego because
of their experience with reality tv and
how do you feel that they fare
i feel like the ego comes into play if
they love the game not because of what
made them famous
professionally
i have seen celebrities come in and
because they've watched like every
season or almost every season
that's when they feel like oh i've got
this and they love knowing like the
little code you know initials like oh
we're gonna play hoh tonight oh you know
what that is that's head of household
yeah then we got pov yeah that's you
know paravito so i see the ego come into
play up with knowledge of this game but
knowledge of this game is not always
translated into wisdom in the game
it's true it can be a curse
it's true because chris kirkpatrick he
has said he's a huge fan of the game and
yeah as soon as you hear that you're
like okay be careful we've seen what
happens in the past
yeah breathe take a beat
you know learn from past celebrity house
guests or past
houseguests or uber fans who played
too much
you know too fast too hard but
do know you have to kind of like
put your foot on the pedal because
because it's celebrities we've got to do
a fast forward version of this game we
have to kick out people every monday and
friday so there is a little bit of okay
i
gotta bond with this one i gotta scheme
against this one i gotta compete i gotta
like study the wall i gotta memorize
what did julie say you know
it is a little bit play fast
but pace yourself yeah i got the wrap
but throw it the name that you're
keeping your eye on this season
well keeping my eye on todrick hall
because he's an uber fan and i'm a fan
of his and i think he's smart um todd
bridges because i grew up watching him
you know um and we're around the same
age so you know i kind of i have that
uh affinity bias of people
around my age um
and i love carson cressley i mean he's
so fabulous and funny and you know
i think i might have met him a couple of
times very briefly but i don't know him
well
so just because i like his tv
personality yeah i'm kind of pulling for
him yeah he's great julie's so nice
getting to talk to you congrats on the
new season
thank you so much